Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on CaseFiles Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to catch. cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and ad-free, you can support case file on your preferred platform. It was around 4.30am on Tuesday, May 11, 2021, when Harrow Lambos and Ognosopoulos, better known as Babas, was violently woken in bed.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码建议，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集节目的说明。本集最初是在 CaseFiles Patreon、Apple Premium 和 Spotify Premium 订阅源上作为付费订阅者的早期奖励发布的。这些剧集旨在缩短时长，以便我们涵盖更广泛的案件。要提前收听这些无广告的剧集，您可以在您偏好的平台上支持 Casefile。2021年5月11日星期二凌晨4点30分左右，哈拉兰博斯·阿纳格诺斯托普洛斯（Harrow Lambos and Ognosopoulos，简称巴巴斯）在睡梦中被暴力惊醒。
Babas rented a two-story mazenet in the affluent suburb of Glicka Nara on the outskirts of Athens, Greece. He had little time to react as three intruders wearing hoods and motorcycle balaclavas grabbed him. A scuffle ensued, but Babas was quickly overpowered by the men who were armed with pistols. They swiftly tied Babas up and blindfolded him with duct tape. Babas could do little as the intruders launched on his wife, 19-year-old Caroline Crouch. The chaos startled the couple's 11-month-old daughter who was sleeping close by and began to cry. The men spoke in broken Greek with Albanian accents. They repeatedly asked, where is the money? Days earlier, Babas and Caroline had bought a plot of land to build their dream family home.
巴巴斯在希腊雅典郊外富裕的格利卡内拉区租了一栋两层复式公寓。他还没来得及反应，三名戴着头套和摩托车面罩的入侵者就抓住了他。双方发生了扭打，但巴巴斯很快被持枪的歹徒制服。他们迅速将巴巴斯捆绑起来，并用胶带蒙住他的眼睛。当入侵者袭击他19岁的妻子卡罗琳·克劳奇（Caroline Crouch）时，巴巴斯无能为力。混乱惊醒了睡在附近的一对夫妇11个月大的女儿，她开始哭泣。歹徒用带有阿尔巴尼亚口音的蹩脚希腊语交谈。他们反复问：“钱在哪里？”几天前，巴巴斯和卡罗琳刚买了一块地，准备建造他们梦想中的家庭住宅。
Caroline's parents had gifted them 50,000 euros to facilitate the purchase. In preparation for construction costs, the couple had hidden a little over 10,000 euros in their house. It was common for people in Greece to store cash at home, as the banks were unreliable and in constant risk of bankruptcy. Wanting to end their torment quickly, Babas told the intruders exactly where they could find the money. It was stored inside a monopoly board game box. The men pocketed the loot, but remained in the house, roaming from room to room, snatching jewelry and other valuables. They demanded more money. With nothing else to offer, all Babas and Caroline could do was beg for their lives. The intruders then held a gun against
卡罗琳的父母赠送了他们5万欧元以促成此次购买。为了准备建筑费用，这对夫妇在家里藏了略多于1万欧元的现金。在希腊，人们在家里存放现金是很常见的，因为银行不可靠且时刻面临破产风险。为了尽快结束折磨，巴巴斯告诉入侵者他们可以在哪里找到钱。钱藏在一个大富翁棋盘游戏的盒子里。歹徒拿走了赃款，但仍留在屋内，在各个房间走动，抢走珠宝和其他贵重物品。他们索要更多的钱。由于没有其他东西可给，巴巴斯和卡罗琳只能乞求他们饶命。随后，入侵者用枪抵住
the baby's head. Caroline began screaming. Babas couldn't see what was happening, but his wife's panicked screams soon fell silent. Babas fought desperately against his restraints. The tape around his neck was painfully tight, and he kept it drifting in and out of consciousness. Babas awoke after one fainting spell to discover the man had gone. The only thing he could hear was his daughter wailing.
婴儿的头部。卡罗琳开始尖叫。巴巴斯看不见发生了什么，但他妻子惊恐的尖叫声很快消失了。巴巴斯拼命挣扎试图摆脱束缚。他脖子上的胶带勒得非常紧，他感到意识时有时无。在一次昏厥后醒来时，巴巴斯发现歹徒已经离开了。他唯一能听到的就是女儿的哭声。
It took about half an hour, but Babas finally manoeuvred himself over to his mobile phone. Using his nose, he dialed the number for emergency service. Upon hearing the operator on the other line, Babas cried out, Help, help, ambulance, ambulance. The duct tape around his mouth muffled his words and he was barely intelligible. The operator asked him to calm down and explain what was going on.
大约过了半小时，巴巴斯终于挪动到了手机旁。他用鼻子拨打了紧急服务电话。听到电话那头的接线员声音时，巴巴斯大喊：“救命，救命，救护车，救护车。”他嘴上的胶带使他的话语变得模糊不清，几乎无法辨认。接线员让他冷静下来，并解释发生了什么事。
Robbers came in, was all Babus managed, before he broke down. Where are you, the operator asked. Glicka Nera, Glicka Nera, Babass yelled. By the time first responders arrived, it was approaching 6am. They raced up the front steps and entered the home. The living space and kitchen had been ransacked. Draws were open and empty, with belongings and clothing strewn about. A monopoly box lay open on the floor.
“强盗进来了，”巴巴斯只说了这些，随后就崩溃了。“你在哪里？”接线员问。“格利卡内拉，格利卡内拉，”巴巴斯大喊。当急救人员赶到时，时间已接近凌晨6点。他们冲上门前的台阶进入屋内。起居室和厨房被洗劫一空。抽屉敞开且空空如也，财物和衣物散落一地。一个大富翁盒子丢在地板上。
A small indoor security camera had been torn off a living room. wall and left behind a couch. Its memory card was missing. Dangling from a staircase banister was a brown and white husky puppy. She was hanging by her own leash, dead. Upstairs in the main bedroom, police found Babas Sanognostopoulos on the floor, his hands and feet restrained tightly behind his back. His eyes and mouth were covered in duct tape that circled down to his neck, Laying face down on the bed nearby was Caroline Crouch. Her baby girl was half on top of her crying while clapping, pushing and hitting her mother's body, doing anything she could to rouse her.
一个小型室内监控摄像头被从客厅墙上扯下，丢在沙发后面。它的存储卡不见了。楼梯扶手上挂着一只棕白相间的哈士奇幼犬。它被自己的牵引绳吊着，已经死了。在楼上的主卧里，警察发现巴巴斯·阿纳格诺斯托普洛斯躺在地板上，手脚被紧紧反绑在身后。他的眼睛和嘴巴被胶带封住，胶带一直缠绕到脖子上。卡罗琳·克劳奇脸朝下躺在附近的床上。她的小女儿半趴在她身上，一边哭一边拍打、推搡着母亲的身体，竭尽全力想唤醒她。
Although the baby was in distress, she was physically unharmed. Caroline, on the other hand, was so pale, it was immediately clear she was deceased. Babas was released. When he saw his wife's body, he was visibly shocked. Is Caroline dead, he asked, before cradling his infant daughter? Once the child was safe with an officer, Babas detailed the violent home invasion. Based on his account and an examination of the crime scene, police concluded that three men had broken in while a fourth kept a watch outside. They'd likely followed an obscured dirt path that led to the rear of the house.
虽然婴儿受到了惊吓，但身体并未受伤。而卡罗琳脸色苍白，显然已经死亡。巴巴斯被松绑。当他看到妻子的尸体时，明显受到了惊吓。“卡罗琳死了吗？”他问，随后抱起他年幼的女儿。当孩子被交给一名警官安全照看后，巴巴斯详细描述了这次暴力入室抢劫。根据他的陈述和对犯罪现场的检查，警方断定有三名男子闯入，第四名男子在外面放哨。他们很可能是沿着一条隐蔽的土路走到房子后部的。
Upon failing to break into a back door, they removed security pins from a basement window and climbed in through that. Once inside, the men silenced the family's seven-month-old Husky, Roxy, by choking her with her leash and throwing her over the banister, strangling her to death. The men then confronted Babas and Caroline asleep in the bed. bedroom. They spent over an hour ransacking the house before Caroline was smothered to death with a pillow. A coroner concluded Caroline had endured an agonising, not instant death, with the attack lasting up to six minutes. Bruising on her lips and tongue appeared to have been caused by a sharp object. Other bruises across Caroline's body indicated she'd put up a fight, but there were no signs of sexual assault. Babas's description of coming in and out of consciousness suggested he had
在试图从后门闯入失败后，他们拆除了地下室窗户的安全销，并从那里爬了进去。进入屋内后，歹徒用牵引绳勒死并将其扔过扶手，杀死了这家人七个月大的哈士奇Roxy，使其噤声。随后，歹徒在卧室里与熟睡的巴巴斯和卡罗琳对峙。他们在屋内搜刮了一个多小时，最后卡罗琳被枕头闷死。验尸官断定卡罗琳经历了一场痛苦的、并非瞬间的死亡，袭击持续了长达六分钟。她嘴唇和舌头上的淤青似乎是由尖锐物体造成的。卡罗琳身上其他部位的淤青表明她曾进行过反抗，但没有性侵迹象。巴巴斯关于意识时有时无的描述表明他
suffered hypoxia, a potentially fatal lack of oxygen. The intruders likely mistook Babas for dead and left, thinking there were no witnesses to their crime. Babus would have died too had his attackers not inadvertently left him with a tiny field of vision through his ductate blindfold. This enabled him to find his nightstand where his mobile phone was located. Despite the damage done to the couple's home, the perpetrators had left no clear evidence behind. Yet, one of the men's balaclavas had slipped during the initial struggle with Babas and he'd gotten a brief glimpse of the man. A composite sketch was created, depicting a tall, dark-skinned, overweight male who was under 30 years old. Babbas was also able to identify two of the handguns the assailants were carrying, a silver
患有缺氧症，这是一种可能致命的缺氧状态。入侵者很可能误以为巴巴斯已经死亡并离开了，认为他们的罪行没有目击者。如果袭击者没有无意中让他通过胶带眼罩留下一小块视野，巴巴斯也会死。这使他能够找到放置手机的床头柜。尽管这对夫妇的家遭到破坏，但肇事者没有留下任何明确的证据。然而，其中一名歹徒的面罩在与巴巴斯最初的扭打中滑落，他短暂地瞥见了那个人。警方绘制了一张合成素描，描绘了一名身材高大、皮肤黝黑、超重且不到30岁的男性。巴巴斯还认出了袭击者携带的两把手枪，一把是银色的
colt and a black pistol. All up, the perpetrators escaped with over 10,000 euros in cash and around 20,000 euros worth of jewellery. Police were certain those responsible were professional criminals. They had likely watched Babas and Caroline for some time, familiarising themselves with the family's routine before choosing the opportune moment to strike. While gang-led killings were not unusual in Greece, the slaughter of a mother in front of her baby shocked the country. A police spokesperson said, We've seen several other ugly murders throughout the years, but this was extremely brutal and
柯尔特手枪，另一把是黑色手枪。总共，肇事者抢走了超过1万欧元的现金和价值约2万欧元的珠宝。警方确信肇事者是职业罪犯。他们很可能已经监视巴巴斯和卡罗琳一段时间，在选择最佳时机下手前熟悉了这家人的作息。虽然帮派主导的杀戮在希腊并不罕见，但当着婴儿的面屠杀母亲震惊了全国。一位警方发言人表示：“多年来我们见过其他几起丑陋的谋杀案，但这起案件极其残忍且
violent. It took someone with a strong anti-social personality and a distinct lack of emotion to carry out such a heinous act. One investigator remarked, In a robbery, the motive is money. It was not necessary to kill to achieve this goal. Therefore, the question on everyone's minds was, why was Caroline Crouch killed? It was speculated that the intruders had been high on drugs and unable to control their actions. Perhaps Caroline got a decent look at them, or knew them. Caroline was also a black belt kickboxer. She might have fought back with a level of strength or skill the invaders didn't anticipate,
暴力。”实施如此令人发指的行为需要一个具有强烈反社会人格且明显缺乏情感的人。一名调查员评论道：“在抢劫中，动机是钱。为了达到这个目的，没必要杀人。因此，每个人心中的疑问是，为什么卡罗琳·克劳奇会被杀？”有人推测入侵者可能吸了毒，无法控制自己的行为。也许卡罗琳看清了他们的长相，或者认识他们。卡罗琳还是一位黑带跆拳道选手。她可能以入侵者未预料到的力量或技巧进行了反抗，
so they killed her to keep her under control. Maybe her frantic screaming after a gun was pressed to her daughter's temple forced them to silence her before alarms were raised. Given that the perpetrators knew to ask for the money the couple had stashed away, the only thing investigators ascertained with any degree, of certainty was that the attack was premeditated. Those in Babas and Carolines's inner circle were questioned. Perhaps someone among them had tipped off the gang.
所以他们杀了她以控制局面。也许她在枪口抵住女儿太阳穴后的疯狂尖叫迫使他们必须让她噤声，以免引来警报。鉴于肇事者知道索要这对夫妇藏起来的钱，调查人员唯一能确定的是，这次袭击是预谋好的。巴巴斯和卡罗琳核心圈子的人都受到了盘问。也许他们中间有人向帮派通风报信。
Meanwhile, security footage collected from nearby homes and businesses showed a dark-colored car cruising around the couple's house on the morning of the crime. It was closely followed by a motorbike. The vehicles were filmed to, turning along the streets that led to Babas and Caroline's home. Three days after her murder, Caroline Crouch was laid to rest on the Greek island of Alonisos. She'd lived there since she was two, her parents having fallen in love with the idyllic coastal surroundings and decided to relocate there from England.
与此同时，从附近住宅和企业收集的监控录像显示，案发当天早上，一辆深色汽车在受害夫妇家周围徘徊。紧随其后的是一辆摩托车。这些车辆被拍到转入通往巴巴斯和卡罗琳家的街道。谋杀发生三天后，卡罗琳·克劳奇被安葬在希腊阿洛尼索斯岛。她从两岁起就住在那儿，她的父母爱上了那里田园诗般的海岸环境，决定从英国搬到那里。
Caroline embraced her beachside upbringing, developing a passion for scuba diving and swimming. It was on Alonisos. during a Good Friday parade in 2017, where Caroline met and fell in love with Babas and Agnostopoulos, a handsome and successful commercial helicopter pilot. Paying tribute to his late wife, Babas said, I was lucky that I met you, very lucky that you loved me and even more lucky that you are the mother of my child. She will grow up not remembering her wonderful mother, but Caroline, who was the joy of life, will always be near me, through our daughter. Case File will be back shortly.
卡罗琳拥抱了她的海滨成长环境，培养了对水肺潜水和游泳的热情。正是在阿洛尼索斯，2017年耶稣受难日游行期间，卡罗琳遇见并爱上了巴巴斯·阿纳格诺斯托普洛斯，一位英俊且事业有成的商业直升机飞行员。在悼念已故妻子时，巴巴斯说：“我很幸运遇见了你，非常幸运你爱我，更幸运的是你是我们孩子的母亲。她长大后不会记得她出色的母亲，但卡罗琳，那个生命的快乐源泉，将永远通过我们的女儿陪伴在我身边。”Case File稍后回来。
Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. As Caroline Crouch was being laid to rest, police in northeast Greece pulled a car over for a routine stop. The 36-year-old male driver was a Georgian national who was on route to the Bulgarian border. He handed over his passport for identification, but it was quickly determined to be a fake. As it turned out, the man was Georgi Harrodsishwili, a violent criminal with multiple convictions.
感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 CaseFile 继续提供优质内容。当卡罗琳·克劳奇被安葬时，希腊东北部的警察拦下了一辆车进行例行检查。36岁的男司机是一名格鲁吉亚公民，正前往保加利亚边境。他交出了护照以供身份识别，但很快被确定为伪造。事实证明，此人是乔治·哈拉兹什维利（Georgi Haradzishvili），一名有多次定罪记录的暴力罪犯。
He was wanted in relation to 12 break-ins committed around Athens over the past six months. Three were around Caroline Croucher's neighbourhood of Glicka Nera. One was in December the previous year. Harrodzishwili and three others broke into a house via a rear window and dragged the female occupant by her hair before threatening to slit her throat. The offenders made off with almost 10,000 euros in cash as well as jewelry. On March 7, two months before Babas and Kemp, Caroline were targeted, Haradzishwili and four accomplices tied up an elderly couple and their
他因过去六个月在雅典周围犯下的12起入室盗窃案而被通缉。其中三起发生在卡罗琳·克劳奇所在的格利卡内拉社区。一起发生在去年12月。哈拉兹什维利和其他三人通过后窗闯入一户人家，抓住女住户的头发，威胁要割断她的喉咙。罪犯抢走了近1万欧元的现金以及珠宝。3月7日，在巴巴斯和卡罗琳成为目标的前两个月，哈拉兹什维利和四名同伙在一次入室抢劫中捆绑了一对老年夫妇和他们的
cleaning lady during a home invasion. They made off with cash and other valuables. Harad Zishwili bore remarkable similarities to the composite sketch Babas had helped create. Given his Georgian roots, history of carrying out violent break-ins with a gang and his attempt to flee the country, police were confident that they had filed. finally found Caroline's killer. Georgie Haradzishwili was placed under arrest. He was interrogated for four days straight, during which he was tied up and beaten by interviewing officers.
清洁女工。他们抢走了现金和其他贵重物品。哈拉兹什维利与巴巴斯协助绘制的合成素描惊人地相似。鉴于他的格鲁吉亚背景、与帮派进行暴力入室抢劫的历史以及他试图逃离国家的行为，警方确信他们终于找到了卡罗琳的杀手。乔治·哈拉兹什维利被逮捕。他连续接受了四天的审讯，期间被审讯人员捆绑并殴打。
They asked over and over, how did you get out there? How did you get in the house? How did you kill her? Haradzishwili's treatment at the hands of police left him concussed. He maintained that he had never heard of Caroline Crouch, and when evidence against him came up dry, Harad Zishwili was cleared of any involvement in her murder. Three officers were demoted from the Athens Homicide Squad for the treatment Georgie Haradzishwili endured while in custody.
他们反复问：“你是怎么出去的？你是怎么进屋的？你是怎么杀她的？”哈拉兹什维利在警方手中的遭遇让他脑震荡。他坚称自己从未听说过卡罗琳·克劳奇，当针对他的证据落空时，哈拉兹什维利被排除了与她谋杀案的任何关联。三名雅典凶杀组的警官因乔治·哈拉兹什维利在拘留期间遭受的待遇而被降职。
Police set their sights on a local Albanian organised crime group. Eventually, they whittled a list of 100 potential suspects down to just to just. 10 people. These individuals were on what detectives referred to as the red list, known criminals with a penchant for being particularly cruel. Babas and Anagnostopoulos was shown mugshots of the suspects, though police wouldn't divulge any further insight into their identities. They're all hardcore criminals of different nationalities. Albanians, Georgians and Greeks may all have been involved. Organised crime knows no frontiers, was all a detective was willing to say, before adding. It's a difficult case. It's taken longer than we thought to get here, but we are getting closer.
警方将目光投向了当地的一个阿尔巴尼亚有组织犯罪集团。最终，他们将100名潜在嫌疑人的名单缩小到了仅10人。这些人处于侦探所称的“红名单”上，都是以残忍著称的已知罪犯。巴巴斯·阿纳格诺斯托普洛斯被展示了嫌疑人的照片，尽管警方没有透露关于他们身份的任何进一步信息。“他们都是不同国籍的铁杆罪犯。阿尔巴尼亚人、格鲁吉亚人和希腊人都可能参与其中。有组织犯罪没有国界，”一名侦探在补充道之前只愿意说这些。“这是一个困难的案件。走到这一步比我们预想的要花更长时间，但我们正在接近真相。”
Members of the public were starting to lose patience as racial hostilities grew. A 300,000 euro reward for information went unclaimed. Meanwhile, robberies and burglaries continue. throughout Athens, leaving residents fearful someone else would soon be killed. A criminologist told The Sun Online, If this was an ordinary burglary, it would have been solved by now. We read that there is no DNA, no fingerprints, that there is little evidence, and yet they seem like amateurs. Something is not right. But Caroline's loved ones remained grateful for the investigative effort, with her husband,
随着种族敌对情绪的增长，公众开始失去耐心。一笔30万欧元的线索悬赏金无人认领。与此同时，雅典各地的抢劫和入室盗窃案仍在继续，让居民担心很快会有其他人被杀。一位犯罪学家告诉《太阳报》在线版：“如果这是一起普通的入室盗窃案，现在应该已经解决了。我们读到没有DNA，没有指纹，几乎没有证据，然而他们看起来像业余爱好者。有些事情不对劲。”但卡罗琳的亲人仍然感谢调查工作，她的丈夫
telling reporters. I hope what happened to me and my family and my wife's family never happens again. The police know how to do their job, and they will find them. Despite the emotional toll, Babas continued to front the media to keep his wife's case in the public consciousness. He willingly fielded questions from journalists via his Instagram account, while expressing his gratitude for the outpouring of support he was receiving from around the world. On June 17, 2021, 37 days after Caroline Crouch was killed,
告诉记者：“我希望发生在我、我的家人和我妻子家人身上的事永远不要再发生。警察知道如何做好他们的工作，他们会找到他们的。”尽管承受着情感上的痛苦，巴巴斯继续面对媒体，以保持他妻子的案件在公众意识中。他通过自己的Instagram账户自愿回答记者的问题，同时表达了他对来自世界各地的支持浪潮的感激之情。2021年6月17日，即卡罗琳·克劳奇被杀37天后，
police revealed they were closer than ever to tracking down her killer, though they didn't elaborate. That same day, a small memorial service was held for Caroline on Alonisos. Morners soon noticed that detectives had arrived. The detectives waited for the service to conclude before discreetly approaching Babas' Sanognostopoulos and asking him to escort them to Athens. Important information had emerged and there was a new suspect. They urged Babas to come and help identify the man. Babas agreed.
警方透露他们比以往任何时候都更接近追踪到她的杀手，尽管他们没有详细说明。同一天，卡罗琳在阿洛尼索斯举行了一场小型追悼会。哀悼者很快注意到侦探们已经到达。侦探们等待仪式结束后，谨慎地接近巴巴斯·阿纳格诺斯托普洛斯，要求他陪同他们前往雅典。重要信息已经浮出水面，出现了一名新嫌疑人。他们敦促巴巴斯前来协助辨认此人。巴巴斯同意了。
He approached Caroline's mother, Susan, to give her the update. He gave her a tearful embrace before preparing to depart for Athens. Investigators had followed up a host of leads that a emerged from Babas's recollections of the night his wife was killed, but all had reached dead ends. Over time, several details didn't appear to add up. Detectives had failed to uncover indisputable evidence that the basement window had been breached by intruders. The window was very small, raising doubts that several men, one of whom Babas said was tall and overweight, could access the house in this way.
他走近卡罗琳的母亲苏珊，告诉她最新情况。他给了她一个泪流满面的拥抱，然后准备出发前往雅典。调查人员跟进了巴巴斯对妻子被杀之夜的回忆中浮现出的许多线索，但都陷入了死胡同。随着时间的推移，一些细节似乎对不上。侦探们未能发现地下室窗户被入侵者闯入的确凿证据。窗户非常小，这引起了怀疑，即几名男子（其中一名巴巴斯说是高大且超重）能否以这种方式进入房子。
And although Babbis and Caroline's house had been ransacked, something about the mess felt remarkably polished for a violent home invasion. The only thing a neighbour had heard was the sound of the couple's puppy crying in distress. They didn't hear any ransacking, screams, calls for help, or a baby crying. Most perplexing was the absence of foreign fingerprints
尽管巴巴斯和卡罗琳的房子被洗劫一空，但这种混乱对于一场暴力入室抢劫来说显得过于刻意。邻居唯一听到的声音是这对夫妇的幼犬痛苦的哭声。他们没有听到任何翻箱倒柜的声音、尖叫声、求救声或婴儿的哭声。最令人困惑的是没有外国人的指纹
or biological material in the house. This was unheard of, and investigators wondered how the offenders had gotten so lucky. It was also unusual for home invaders to restrain a male victim and leave him unharmed while opting to fight a female victim. Not a single piece of forensic evidence was uncovered on Caroline's body, despite the fact she had fought her attacker for upwards of six minutes. Even swabs taken from underneath her fingernails came back negative for any outside DNA. Then there was the matter of the home security camera which was found damaged in the living room.
或生物材料留在屋内。这闻所未闻，调查人员想知道罪犯是如何如此幸运的。入室抢劫者捆绑男性受害者并让他毫发无损，同时选择攻击女性受害者也是不寻常的。卡罗琳的尸体上没有发现任何法医证据，尽管她曾与袭击者搏斗了长达六分钟。甚至从她指甲下提取的拭子也显示没有外部DNA。然后是客厅里发现受损的家庭监控摄像头的问题。
It is common for criminals to take security cameras with them, but in this instance, the offender had merely removed the memory card. Data revealed the card had been removed at 120am, yet Babas said the thieves broke in at 4.30 a.m. At the time of her death, Caroline Crouch was wearing a smartwatch that automatically monitored her pulse. At 358 a.m., her heart rate indicated she was fast asleep. At 405, her pulse increased abruptly by 50%, showing she was in an extreme state of mental or physical stress. At 4.11 a.m., Caroline's heart stopped beating altogether.
罪犯带走监控摄像头很常见，但在这种情况下，罪犯仅仅取出了存储卡。数据显示卡片是在凌晨1点20分被取出的，但巴巴斯说小偷是在凌晨4点30分闯入的。在去世时，卡罗琳·克劳奇戴着一块自动监测脉搏的智能手表。凌晨3点58分，她的心率显示她睡得很熟。凌晨4点05分，她的脉搏突然增加了50%，显示她处于极度的精神或身体压力状态。凌晨4点11分，卡罗琳的心脏完全停止了跳动。
This too was before the time Babas said she must have been murdered. An examination of Babas's phone revealed he had a fitness app installed that tracked his physical activity. Data from the night of the crime showed he was moving around at the exact time he'd supposedly been tied up and blindfolded by the alleged intruders. Police also attempted to re-enact Babas's claim that he used his nose to dial emergency services on his phone's touchscreen. At the time, he'd been tightly restrained from head to toe and blindfolded with duct tape. No officer was able to successfully dial the number while in the same condition. Investigators also uncovered evidence that Caroline had attempted to book herself and her daughter into a hotel on the night of her murder.
这也早于巴巴斯所说的她被谋杀的时间。对巴巴斯手机的检查显示，他安装了一个追踪身体活动的健身应用程序。案发当晚的数据显示，在他声称被所谓的入侵者捆绑和蒙住眼睛的同一时间，他正在走动。警方还试图重演巴巴斯声称他用鼻子在手机触摸屏上拨打紧急服务的说法。当时，他被从头到脚紧紧捆绑，并用胶带蒙住了眼睛。没有警官能在同样的情况下成功拨出号码。调查人员还发现了证据，表明卡罗琳在被谋杀当晚曾试图为自己和女儿预订酒店。
A text she sent to a friend around this time revealed why. Caroline had threatened to leave her husband. Babas and Ognostopoulos had been on holiday in Alonisos when he first met Caroline Crouch. His mother lived on the island and was a teacher at the school Caroline attended. Caroline was just 15 years old when Babas introduced himself. He was 27. Described as charismatic, clever and photogenic, he was also well off financially.
她在大约这个时候发给朋友的一条短信揭示了原因。卡罗琳曾威胁要离开她的丈夫。巴巴斯·阿纳格诺斯托普洛斯在阿洛尼索斯度假时第一次见到卡罗琳·克劳奇。他的母亲住在岛上，是卡罗琳就读学校的一名老师。巴巴斯自我介绍时，卡罗琳年仅15岁。他27岁。他被描述为富有魅力、聪明且上镜，经济上也相当宽裕。
Babas gained Caroline's attention by flying his helicopter over the school. Despite the 12-year age gap, Caroline believed she had found her perfect match and assured her family that she was happy. Within a year and a half, Babas proposed to the then-17-year-old Caroline. Three days after Caroline turned 18, the pair exchanged vows and settled in Glicka Nera.
巴巴斯通过驾驶直升机飞过学校来吸引卡罗琳的注意。尽管有12岁的年龄差距，卡罗琳相信她找到了完美的伴侣，并向家人保证她很幸福。一年半内，巴巴斯向当时17岁的卡罗琳求婚。卡罗琳年满18岁三天后，两人交换了誓言并在格利卡内拉定居。
Caroline attended university in Athens, while Babas continued working as a pilot. Both Caroline and Babas were active on social media, sharing many photos and videos of their life together. Online, they looked like a joyful and romantic couple. Yet, Caroline was far more honest when writing in her private diary. In coded entries dating back to 2019, Caroline questioned her relationship with Babas. That year, she wrote, I fought with Babas again. This time it was serious. I am thinking of leaving. I am thinking of going to my sister. I don't know if I can keep going with him. Over time, Babas became increasingly manipulative and controlling towards Caroline.
卡罗琳在雅典上大学，而巴巴斯继续担任飞行员。卡罗琳和巴巴斯在社交媒体上都很活跃，分享了许多他们共同生活的照片和视频。在网上，他们看起来是一对快乐而浪漫的夫妇。然而，卡罗琳在写私人日记时要诚实得多。在追溯到2019年的加密条目中，卡罗琳质疑她与巴巴斯的关系。那一年，她写道：“我又和巴巴斯吵架了。这次很严重。我在考虑离开。我在考虑去我姐姐那里。我不知道我是否能继续和他在一起。”随着时间的推移，巴巴斯对卡罗琳变得越来越具有操纵性和控制欲。
It began with their very non-traditional wedding. Greek weddings are typically elaborate celebrations attended by a large crowd of family and well-wishes. However, Babas eloped with Caroline overseas in a guestless ceremony. Upon their return home, Babas further isolated Caroline from her friends and family. He was also the breadwinner while Caroline was a university student with no money. making her totally dependent on him. Whenever Caroline's mother sent her money, Babus would take it.
这始于他们非常非传统的婚礼。希腊婚礼通常是由大量家人和祝福者参加的精心庆祝活动。然而，巴巴斯与卡罗琳私奔到海外，举行了一个没有客人的仪式。回到家后，巴巴斯进一步将卡罗琳与她的朋友和家人隔离开来。他还是养家糊口的人，而卡罗琳是一名没有钱的大学生，这使她完全依赖于他。每当卡罗琳的母亲给她寄钱时，巴巴斯就会拿走。
Caroline wrote of her anguish in her diary, quote, I love Babus so much that I can't leave him, even though this relationship hurts me. Caroline later detailed a tearful confrontation she had with Babus, wherein she expressed her desire to leave him. But she had just discovered she was pregnant with his child. Caroline wrote, I stayed with him so my daughter would not grow up without her two parents. In July 2020, Caroline wrote,
卡罗琳在日记中写下了她的痛苦，引用道：“我太爱巴巴斯了，以至于我无法离开他，尽管这段关系伤害了我。”卡罗琳后来详细描述了她与巴巴斯的一次泪流满面的对峙，她在对峙中表达了离开他的愿望。但她刚刚发现自己怀上了他的孩子。卡罗琳写道：“我留在他身边，这样我的女儿就不会在没有父母的情况下长大。”2020年7月，卡罗琳写道：
Today my little one is a month old. It's also the day I told Babas I want to leave. I feel awful. She went on to write that she had found a house for herself in the Athens suburb of Herlandry. Hours before Caroline was killed, phone records revealed that she and Babas had exchanged several combative texts while at home together. Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content.
“今天我的小家伙一个月大了。这也是我告诉巴巴斯我想离开的日子。我感觉糟透了。”她接着写道，她已经在雅典郊区的赫兰德里为自己找了一所房子。在卡罗琳被杀前几个小时，电话记录显示她和巴巴斯在家里在一起时交换了几条充满敌意的短信。Case File稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 CaseFile 继续提供优质内容。
Babas and Ognostopoulos was informed that the suspect who had emerged in his wife's murder investigation was in fact him. He was presented with the overwhelming evidence that revealed the inconsistencies in his original story. After more than eight hours of interrogation, Babas broke down. Babas confessed that on the night of Monday, May 10, 2021, he and Caroline had started arguing early on. Although Caroline's diary entries indicated the couple had had issues from early in their relationship, Babas claimed they only ever thought about their daughter. He said that Caroline was determined to take their child and leave. This angered Babus, who claimed his daughter was his whole life.
巴巴斯·阿纳格诺斯托普洛斯被告知，在他妻子谋杀案调查中出现的嫌疑人实际上就是他自己。他被出示了揭示他最初故事中不一致之处的压倒性证据。经过八个多小时的审讯，巴巴斯崩溃了。巴巴斯承认，在2021年5月10日星期一晚上，他和卡罗琳很早就开始争吵。尽管卡罗琳的日记条目表明这对夫妇从关系初期就有问题，但巴巴斯声称他们只考虑过他们的女儿。他说卡罗琳决心带走他们的孩子并离开。这激怒了巴巴斯，他声称女儿是他生命的全部。
He lost his temper. Babass told police. At some point Caroline threw the child in her cot and she told me to get up and leave. leave the house. She pushed me and punched me. My judgment became blurred. I strangled her. Caroline tried to fight Babass off as he pressed a pillow down on her face with the entire weight of his body. He killed her in front of their 11-month-old daughter. Afterwards, Babas panicked. He thought about getting rid of Caroline's body but said it was impossible for him to do so. He just looked at her and cried. The thought of
他失去了理智。巴巴斯告诉警方：“在某个时刻，卡罗琳把孩子扔进婴儿床，她让我起来离开。离开房子。她推我并打我。我的判断力变得模糊。我勒死了她。”当巴巴斯用全身的重量将枕头压在卡罗琳脸上时，她试图反抗。他在他们11个月大的女儿面前杀死了她。事后，巴巴斯惊慌失措。他想过处理掉卡罗琳的尸体，但说他无法做到。他只是看着她哭泣。然后他脑海中闪过一个念头，
thought then crossed his mind to say someone else killed Caroline. He staged the home invasion, killing their puppy Roxy to bolster his story. He knew no one would believe he was capable of killing his own dog. Babas then placed his wailing baby daughter alongside the body of his wife before tying himself up with rope, duct tape and handcuffs. Babas conceded that he deserved to be punished, saying, I owe a big apology to the people I've hurt. I know it doesn't matter now. What I did was not justified. He did, however, try to shift blame onto Caroline by saying she had become unstable and aggressive since giving birth. He made out that she was a terrible mother and implied that he had killed her to save their child. In Caroline, the murder that fooled the world,
说别人杀了卡罗琳。他策划了入室抢劫，杀死了他们的幼犬Roxy以支持他的故事。他知道没人会相信他有能力杀死自己的狗。巴巴斯随后将他哭泣的幼女放在他妻子的尸体旁，然后用绳子、胶带和手铐将自己捆绑起来。巴巴斯承认他应该受到惩罚，说：“我欠我伤害过的人一个大大的道歉。我知道现在说什么都没用了。我所做的一切是不正当的。”然而，他确实试图通过说卡罗琳自生下孩子后变得不稳定和具有攻击性来推卸责任。他把她描绘成一个糟糕的母亲，并暗示他杀她是为救他们的孩子。在《卡罗琳，欺骗世界的谋杀案》中，
abuse expert, Dr. Emma Katz, said, This attempt to besmirch Caroline's character and make people think badly of her is of course an attempt to get Babas more sympathy and more lenient treatment, which goes completely against the narrative that he has any remorse or contrition for what he's done. In reference to Babas painting Caroline out to be the aggressor, Dr. Katz explained. We do often see victims argue. arguing back, and we see victims even physically fighting back against the coercive control. Sometimes people then think they can't be a real victim, they fought back.
虐待专家艾玛·卡茨（Dr. Emma Katz）博士说：“这种试图玷污卡罗琳名声并让人们对她产生负面看法的行为，当然是试图让巴巴斯获得更多同情和更宽大的处理，这完全违背了他对自己所作所为有任何悔恨或愧疚的说法。”在提到巴巴斯将卡罗琳描绘成侵略者时，卡茨博士解释道：“我们确实经常看到受害者反驳。反驳，我们甚至看到受害者在身体上反抗强制控制。有时人们会认为他们不可能是真正的受害者，因为他们反抗了。”
Babas might have given the impression Caroline wasn't a real victim because she fought back, but in my opinion, she very much was. Babas said he lied to police because he didn't want his daughter to grow up without either of her parents. I'm devastated, he said. I only cared about my daughter. I hid the truth so I would be able to raise her. Greece's chief of police claimed that they had suspected Babas and Ognostopoulos from the beginning. When police first arrived at his home, Babas was remarkably cold about his wife's murder. His demeanour made one officer so uncomfortable she took Babas's baby away from him. Yet, any misgivings about Babas were kept private as investigators ruled out other possibilities.
巴巴斯可能给人留下了卡罗琳不是真正受害者的印象，因为她反抗了，但在我看来，她确实是。巴巴斯说他向警方撒谎是因为他不想让女儿在没有父母的情况下长大。“我崩溃了，”他说。“我只关心我的女儿。我隐瞒了真相，这样我就能抚养她。”希腊警察局长声称他们从一开始就怀疑巴巴斯·阿纳格诺斯托普洛斯。当警察第一次到达他家时，巴巴斯对他妻子的谋杀表现得异常冷漠。他的举止让一名警官感到非常不舒服，以至于她把巴巴斯的婴儿从他身边带走了。然而，对巴巴斯的任何疑虑都被保密，因为调查人员排除了其他可能性。
They publicly refuted any suggestions he was responsible to prevent him from fleeing. Babas was so confident that he had convinced police of his story that he didn't feel the need to destroy evidence, such as his mobile phone. Babas cleverly blamed the crime on foreigners because he knew this would shift public discourse to the perpetrator's national rather than the crime itself. Authorities described Babas as a top-class actor. His willingness to speak to investigators and the media ensured he came across as a man with nothing to hide. In front of news cameras, he convincingly played the role of grieving husband. Many viewers were fully convinced he was a man in pain. Babas told the media, Take care of your family.
他们公开反驳了任何关于他负责的建议，以防止他逃跑。巴巴斯非常自信他已经让警方相信了他的故事，以至于他觉得没有必要销毁证据，比如他的手机。巴巴斯聪明地将罪行归咎于外国人，因为他知道这会将公众讨论转移到肇事者的国籍而不是罪行本身。当局将巴巴斯描述为“顶级演员”。他愿意与调查人员和媒体交谈，确保他给人的印象是一个没有什么可隐瞒的人。在新闻摄像机前，他令人信服地扮演了悲伤丈夫的角色。许多观众完全相信他是一个痛苦的人。巴巴斯告诉媒体：“照顾好你的家人。
Cherish your loved ones as much as you can. While the homicide investigation was underway, Babas was active on social media, posting happy pictures of him and Caroline, along with captions like, Together Forever. He kept up this charade for over a month. Caroline's mother, Susan, later revealed
尽可能珍惜你的亲人。”在凶杀案调查进行期间，巴巴斯在社交媒体上很活跃，发布了他和卡罗琳的快乐照片，并配上“永远在一起”之类的标题。他维持这种伪装了一个多月。卡罗琳的母亲苏珊后来透露
that she hadn't suspected her daughter's husband for a second. She had placed all her husband. her hopes in her son-in-law and was left full of anger upon his confession. The word wife was promptly removed from Caroline Crouch's white marble headstone, leaving the words to our much-loved mother and daughter. Babus was charged with premeditated murder. He also faced charges for perverting the course of justice, lying to authorities and animal abuse. Public opinion about Babus was so vitriolic,
她一秒钟都没有怀疑过她女儿的丈夫。她把所有的希望都寄托在女婿身上，在他坦白后充满了愤怒。单词“妻子”很快从卡罗琳·克劳奇的白色大理石墓碑上移除了，留下了“致我们深爱的母亲和女儿”的字样。巴巴斯被控预谋谋杀。他还面临妨碍司法公正、向当局撒谎和虐待动物的指控。公众对巴巴斯的舆论非常尖刻，
that outside court he donned a bulletproof vest and was flanked by armed police. He was dubbed the most vile man in Greece, though not everyone agreed. A small group of middle-aged women gathered at the court to support the alleged killer. One of the women told the times, By no means do I justify what he did, but he's quite handsome and dashing. Another remarked, He's quite sensitive, not the narcissist they paint him out to be. I think about him a lot.
以至于在法庭外，他穿上了防弹背心，并由武装警察护送。他被称为“希腊最卑鄙的人”，尽管并非所有人都同意。一小群中年妇女聚集在法庭外支持这名被指控的杀手。其中一名妇女告诉《泰晤士报》：“我绝不为他的所作所为辩护，但他相当英俊潇洒。”另一位评论道：“他相当敏感，不是他们描绘的那种自恋者。我经常想起他。”
I've collected pictures of him and pinned them on my bedroom wall. In court, prosecutors walked through Babas's actions leading up to and immediately after Caroline's murder. They argued that each action, from removing the memory card in his home security camera, to meticulously staging the crime scene, indicated someone acting calmly with pre-planned intent. The fact that Babas attacked Caroline as she slept showed the crime was premeditated and cold-blooded. In his day-long testimony, Babas told the court, I ruined my life, I ruined my family's life, I wish I could go back in time. He called his marriage to Caroline a fairy tale.
“我收集了他的照片，并把它们钉在我的卧室墙上。”在法庭上，检察官回顾了巴巴斯在卡罗琳谋杀案发生前后的行为。他们辩称，从移除家庭监控摄像头中的存储卡，到精心策划犯罪现场，每一个动作都表明有人在冷静地进行预先计划的意图。巴巴斯在卡罗琳熟睡时袭击她这一事实表明，这起罪行是预谋且冷血的。在为期一天的证词中，巴巴斯告诉法庭：“我毁了我的生活，我毁了我家人的生活，我希望我能回到过去。”他称他与卡罗琳的婚姻是一个童话故事，
and claimed that her happiness was his absolute priority. He claimed that after Caroline became a mother, she turned moody and was prone to emotional outbursts. This caused him to snap. Babas was expressionless as he detailed the night he killed Caroline. He claimed responsibility for her death, but denied it was murder. maintaining the attack was a crime of passion done in the heat of the moment.
并声称她的幸福是他的绝对优先事项。他声称卡罗琳成为母亲后变得喜怒无常，容易情绪爆发。这导致他崩溃。巴巴斯在详细描述他杀死卡罗琳的那晚时面无表情。他承认对她的死亡负责，但否认这是谋杀，坚持认为袭击是一起在冲动下发生的激情犯罪。
In May 2022, after a month-long trial, the jury unanimously found Babas and Ognostopoulos guilty of all charges. He was sentenced to life imprisonment. Prison life has been difficult for Babas and Ognostopoulos. He has expressed fear for his life after being beaten by men of the nationalities he tried to pin his crimes on. Caroline Crouch was one of 17 women killed by their romantic partner in Greece in 2021. In almost every instance, the victim had tried to enter the relationship before her death. These types of killings fall under the definition of femicide, the killing of women or girls because they are female. In almost 40% of reported femicide cases, the perpetrator is the victim's spouse or partner.
2022年5月，经过一个月的审判，陪审团一致裁定巴巴斯·阿纳格诺斯托普洛斯所有指控成立。他被判处终身监禁。监狱生活对巴巴斯·阿纳格诺斯托普洛斯来说很困难。在被他试图将罪行归咎于其国籍的人殴打后，他表达了对生命的恐惧。卡罗琳·克劳奇是2021年在希腊被伴侣杀害的17名女性之一。在几乎所有情况下，受害者在去世前都曾试图结束这段关系。这类杀戮属于“杀害女性”（femicide）的定义，即因为女性身份而杀害妇女或女孩。在近40%的报告杀害女性案件中，肇事者是受害者的配偶或伴侣。
Issues of domestic abuse weren't openly discussed in Greece, meaning victims like Caroline Crouch suffered in silence. A journalist appearing on the documentary, Caroline, the murder that fooled the world, said, The only positive thing to come out of this case was that the term thamicide has been introduced in the Greek media. This case gave, tragically, an opportunity for the Greek society to realize how deep this problem is. I hope that this case will live long in the Greek society's memory because it will remind us of the many wrong perceptions we have about people, and it will also remind us how much we should look into the issue of domestic violence. Before Caroline Crouch met Babas and Ognostopoulos,
家庭虐待问题在希腊没有被公开讨论，这意味着像卡罗琳·克劳奇这样的受害者在沉默中受苦。一位出现在纪录片《卡罗琳，欺骗世界的谋杀案》中的记者说：“这个案件带来的唯一积极的事情是，‘杀害女性’这个词被引入了希腊媒体。这个案件悲剧性地为希腊社会提供了一个机会，去意识到这个问题有多深。我希望这个案件能在希腊社会的记忆中长存，因为它会提醒我们对人们有很多错误的认知，它也会提醒我们应该多关注家庭暴力问题。”在卡罗琳·克劳奇遇见巴巴斯·阿纳格诺斯托普洛斯之前，
she was a popular young woman, renowned for always having a smile on her face. Others immediately wanted to befriend her, and she was so well-liked that she was like a mini-celebrity in Alonisos. A friend and former neighbour of Carolines said, I consider the people that hadn't met Caroline unlucky. The loss is really great. I really miss her. Caroline was also a loving and doting mother. In what would become the final video she ever posted to her Instagram account,
她是一个受欢迎的年轻女性，以脸上总是挂着微笑而闻名。其他人立刻想和她交朋友，她非常受欢迎，以至于她在阿洛尼索斯就像一个小名人。卡罗琳的一位朋友和前邻居说：“我认为没有见过卡罗琳的人是不幸的。损失真的很大。我真的很想念她。”卡罗琳也是一位充满爱心和慈爱的母亲。在她发布到Instagram账户的最后一段视频中，
Caroline is on the beach by her home, joyfully holding her baby daughter in the air before planting a kiss on her cheek. The little girl is now being cared for by Caroline's parents, David and Susan, on the same Greek island where Caroline herself grew up. When writing about her daughter in her diary, Caroline said, My love for her is stronger than anything in the world. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
卡罗琳在自家海滩上，快乐地将她的小女儿举在空中，然后在她的脸颊上亲吻。这个小女孩现在由卡罗琳的父母大卫和苏珊在卡罗琳自己长大的同一个希腊岛屿上照顾。在日记中写到女儿时，卡罗琳说：“我对她的爱胜过世界上的一切。”本集节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。